planning is about your future about
thinking 20 years or more ahead
this long-term vision is what makes
planning unique
another thing that makes us different is
that we look at things in the round not
just about one topic we bring different
issues together
but we also have to make short term
decisions we deal with fifteen hundred
planning applications every year from
people who want to do things now
we have our own specialist advisors on
trees landscape ecology and historic
buildings to help us with these
decisions
to do this we need to have an adult
conversation with our communities
by exchanging ideas and information
together we can improve team bridge by
writing a long-term plan for our area
community planning workshops are given
the opportunity for that conversation
and we encourage public involvement in
planning applications and proposals to
improve conservation areas development
management is about accepting that
change will happen
but ensuring that it delivers community
benefits and results in a high quality
environment
and finally if people don't play by the
rules we have enforcement powers